and Inferno
moving faster than firefighters can
contain it winds gusting up to 50
kilometers an hour and with the tourists
move to safety
[Music]
it's the locals left with their burning
Island
we find Katarina watching everything she
owns disappear
I have nothing she cries there goes my
house there go my animals I have nothing
left
her husband exasperated
what are we doing it's all burned where
is everybody he says
the fires keep spreading they are
virtually impossible to control moving
from place to place we've been talking
to fire fighters here in fact there's
more arriving just now these are from
Slovakia and they're saying that there's
very little they can do with these
extremely heavy winds and while the
world has been focusing a lot on the
tourists that have been evacuated from
this island it's the locals we've been
trying to get them to speak to us many
so frustrated they don't want to talk on
camera but there is real desperation
here about how much they've lost and
what's happening to their Island many
volunteers have been fighting the Flames
alone we're told there are simply not
enough Crews on roads
the tourist areas were engulfed causing
the largest fire evacuation in Greece's
history almost 20 000 people by Road and
by sea
Jay and his family left on a boat
the winds had changed the skies turned
dark he tells us and they were told to
leave immediately
now he's come back to find their
belongings I'm absolutely wrecked
absolutely exhausted it's just
unprecedented it's awful
but everyone in the local area
you have to say the logos everywhere
have been fantastic helping
everyone with anything they could do
Rhodes is just one of many areas across
Greece that are burning
prime minister kiriakos mitsotakis
addressed Parliament on Monday stating
we are at War
it's the seventh day of wildfires on
roads people say the air support was
slow to arrive and now the winds have
picked up one tells me the fire has
burned all the trees taken all the
mountains it will only stop at the sea
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera kyotari on
the Greek island of Rhodes